[Música]
malena canta el tango como ninguna y en
cada verso pone su corazón
ayuso del suburbio su voz perfuma
tiene pena de bandoneón
tal vez haya en la infancia su voz de
alondra tomó ese tono oscuro de callejón
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando tenía 12 años
grabé este disco con el coro de la
escuela el color de las voces en la tapa
dice vaya a similitud tan particular la
voz y la pintura ambas tienen tonos
colores brillos
desde chica me llamaban la atención las
voces la diversidad de voces y era muy
susceptible al modo en el que me decían
las cosas todavía hoy me sigue pasando
el tonito cuida el tonito
creo que es más perturbador el modo en
el que nos dicen las cosas que lo que
nos dicen la musicalidad del habla la
musicalidad de la voz
entonaciones ritmos acentos silencios
durante todos estos años he visto y
sentido personalmente cuantas cosas como
decía lulu nos pasan acá cuántas cosas
suceden se manifiestan y se guardan
a veces inclusive se nos hace el famoso
nudo en la garganta en este lugar de
tránsito de apertura y de cierre quizás
alguna vez sintieron ustedes el nudo en
la garganta o tienen ganas de cantar y
no lo hacen por miedo al ridículo o por
vergüenza o cantan en el auto porque
total ahí no te escucha a nadie
hoy que somos muchas voces los invito a
escucharse a escucharnos a escuchar el
color de nuestras voces yo en particular
cuando canto muchas veces siento que en
tonos colores
nada
mardarás
na na na para darla
rara
hoy los invito les propongo imaginarse
una cena de negro una negra
pues pueden pueden
[Música]
o una roja
ah
o una a amarilla
o una blanca
se escucharon esas voces esos sonidos
están aquí en este lugar en esta reserva
natural de sonidos que nos acompañan
desde siempre
cada vez que puedo releo
y me resulta muy orientador a una frase
de ser civil farc
que dice el cuerpo despierta a la vez
que se revela la voz y es absolutamente
natural el que desea cantar aspira a
regresar a su cuerpo del mismo modo que
se regresa complace la casa tras años de
larga ausencia
y el canto lo que nos propone siempre es
presencia estar presentes aquí en este
momento con todo lo que somos
en los encuentros individuales y
grupales del taller de la voz solo
proponer una actividad para conocer cómo
sienten sus voces las personas que se
acercan como ves tu voz como la sentís
si tuvo fuera un objeto o un paisaje o
un color o una palabra cuál sería
recuerdo algunas respuestas
tengo voz de rallador
mi voz es un embudo
mi voz es una llave
tengo dos de colibrí
un hilo con pelusas
pero especialmente recuerdo lo que me
dijo un alumno muy querido de 15 años me
dijo que si subo fuera una ropa sería
una ropa interior porque él al cantar se
sentía casi desnudo
y quizás sea ese grado de desnudez ese
grado de verdad de exposición lo que nos
asusta seas cantante o no
nos pone vulnerables
pero esa vulnerabilidad es toda una
oportunidad para expresarnos
al taller de la voz sean personas de
todas las edades quieren aprender a
cantar desatar el nudo de la voz
encontrar su propia voz animarse en
ocasiones a elegir el canto como una
profesión pero creo que por sobre todo
quieren escucharse y ser escuchados
es que a diario nos pasa
en este momento todos nuestros
operadores se encuentran ocupados
intenté más tarde nuevamente
queremos hablar con alguien queremos que
nos escuchen y si esa escucha es
empática
esto genera confianza actúa de llave
mágica de puente comunicacional nos
sentimos en confianza en apertura y en
ese ambiente en ese marco es mucho más
sencillo animarse a cantar
yo veo que al cantar se iluminan las
caras
cambian las expresiones se puente a la
mente y nos abrimos a las emociones o
mejor dicho son las emociones las que
nos sorprenden muchas veces aparece un
recuerdo doloroso o feliz una emoción
retenida en años y lloramos cantamos y
lloramos
de dónde vienen esas emociones donde
estaban guardadas yo creo que aquí en
este lugar preciado en esta reserva
natural y emocional que guarda nuestra
memoria personal familiar y colectiva en
nuestra huella digital por eso invito a
prestar atención a la voz a la
respiración porque tiene mucho para
decirnos cuando le prestamos el oído
cuando la escuchamos de verdad con
atención cuando ponemos la voz en juego
la voz comunica nos abre y expande
contiene y calma
la necesitamos para decir lo que
queremos y debemos decir también agrede
mientras preparaba esta charla recordé
que cuando era chica antes de que
naciera mi hermana yo tenía un amigo
invisible- jugaba mucho tiempo sola mi
amigo invisible- se llamaba aire
jugaba a los dados con él graciela aire
y anotaba todos los puntos no le hacía
trampa
muchas veces aire me ganaba
yo creo que eso era un juego
premonitorio porque hoy soy cantante
tengo una profesión que depende de mi
respiración de algo tan natural como el
aire una profesión inspiradora y
portátil a la que le estoy muy
agradecida muy agradecida
les propongo hacer memoria
recordar a aquellas personas que
escucharon lo que ustedes necesitaban y
querían proponer hacérselo saber
agradecérselo
y por otro lado una tarea un poco
olvidada en estos tiempos que suelo
proponer en los encuentros de voces y
que resulta muy reveladora sentarse a
escribir una carta una carta a la voz a
la voz de ustedes
hace tiempo para mis libros escribí la
mía
querida vos me propusiste viajes recorre
y mi cuerpo siempre llevándome más allá
y trayendo me de vuelta a mi vocera de
mí misma gracias a vos
atravieso emociones diversas encuentro
mi silencio te dejo con algo que siempre
nos gusta hacer juntas
tu canción tiene el frío del último
encuentro tu canción se hace amarga en
la sal del recuerdo yo no sé
si tu voz es la flor de una pena solo se
que el rumor de tus tangos malena te
siento más buena
más buena que yo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]